this is my home
this is my kitchen
this is my family Tilly Jack
Holly Megan
[Music]
and of course my wife Tana
you may think you're the busiest person
in the world but over this series I'm
gonna prove it's still possible to cook
stunning food at home
[Music]
my rules are simple home cooking has to
be easy
it's gonna be fast it's got to be
delicious
so if you think you can't cook amazing
food at home think again
these are the only recipes you'll ever
need breakfast lunch and dinner
starting out as a young Chef my biggest
influence was definitely French cuisine
and when I was 23 years of age I was
determined to learn as much as I could
so I set off for Paris to work in some
of the most demanding and exacting
kitchens in the world and my passion and
love the French food really took hold
first up for breakfast a French
Patisserie delicacy madeleines those
shells of a light sponge flavored with
lemon and poppy seed
for lunch my take on a French classic
the salad nicoise with a gutsy Caper and
anchovy dressing
accompanied by delicious pear and creamy
goat cheese Tartine
utility and my youngest Tilly gets a
taste for French cooking as we create
chicken fricassee
so with Herbie sauteed potatoes followed
by lavender creme caramel this is my
ultimate French food breakfast lunch and
dinner my ultimate French breakfast
isn't complex or flashy it's just simple
elegant and delicious
the secret to a really good Madeleine is
it's light fluffy delicious and it's
perfect
with the coffee in the morning so melt
the butter gently next
three eggs
[Music]
that was one of the most exciting things
about living in Paris there was always
something there and that little pastry
shop that I used to live above I'm gonna
incorporate the sugar
and then give that a really good whisk
because it's important to incorporate
some air now the secret to whisking is a
big beautiful balloon whisk
the bigger the balloon whisk the more
aeration you'll get in the mixture so
the best thing to do
is just go from left to right and then
change hands
every 15 or 20 seconds
so your hands never get tired you tilt
the ball to your advantage as well
now you can see the mixture starting to
aerate
it's almost double in size
[Music]
the more you whisk this the lighter it
becomes
so it starts to almost look like a light
whipped cream
gone as that dark Rich egg yolk color
beautiful
once the eggs and sugar become pale
creamy and thick sift in the
self-raising flour
serving the flour
now I'll give my madeleines a Twist by
adding poppy seeds for a crunch and
lemon for flavor a zest of a lemon in
there
generous on the lemon
lime is wonderful
orange zest again beautiful I've even
made pink grapefruit madeleines with
poppy seeds delicious but lemon for me
is the best
pour the melted butter down the side of
the bowl
so it cools down even more and then
combine start mixing that in it's really
important at this stage that we don't
beat
the mixture I want to keep that nice
aerated texture across the Madeleine mix
so I'm going to use a spatula now and
just gently mix my butter in
now give that a good mix
and they say that the longer you make
the mix up in advance
the higher they raise in the oven
look at that it looks beautiful leave
that to sit there
[Music]
and we'll butter and line our molds
you can make these in little miniature
Yorkshire pudding molds I've even seen
Madeleine's been cooked in espresso cups
so if you haven't got the traditional
Madeleine tray Yorkshire pudding trays
are just as good lightly butter
the inside of the tray take a tablespoon
of flour
and the secret now is to line the mold
with the flour that stops any chance of
the Madeleine sticking
tap the sieve
into all the little grooves
and this will ensure that they'll come
out instantly
then all you do then is just stand up
the tray and tap it two or three times
and you'll see the flower roll out
so there you go
the baking sheet lined beautifully no
excess butter and no excess flour the
beauty of this recipe is that you can
make it the night before and then simply
bake it in the morning
when you're ready to go put the mixture
into a jug to make it really easy to
pour into the tin
give it a little stir
so you've got that nice even
distribution of those poppy seeds and
just gently
lovely
firm up to the top oh beautiful
so much easier pouring this from a jug
because you get the exact amount in into
the oven 180 degrees do not open that
door before 10 minutes
and wait for that wonderful surprise
[Music]
they smell amazing
now
a little tap on the side of the tray
and they just all pop out if you should
be done
that smell is unique
that nice soft
crisp outside with this lovely fragrant
fluffy Center
and the secret of a great Madeleine
as the French would swear by it is his
lovely little Mound on top
they call it the nipple
but
that is the confirmation that is perfect
my poppy and lemon madeleines are a
sophisticated content will start to the
day and take me straight back to Paris
[Music]
coming up I'll be showing you a
fantastic French inspired lunch and
dinner
[Music]
but first here's a look at some of the
key ingredients you'll need to add a bit
of garlic Flair to your cooking
[Music]
the one ingredient most associated with
French food is garlic and it's no
surprise almost every one of my French
recipes has it in
[Music]
garlic is a member of the allium or
onion family and comes in all shapes and
sizes and strengths Pink garlic from
latrek in Southwest France is considered
the finest with a strong sweet taste
elephant garlic has massive bulbs and a
much milder flavor but today I'm using a
common white type you get in all the
supermarkets it's a great all-rounder
[Music]
Brandy really is the ultimate Spirit of
France it's made from either distilled
grapes or fruit
Armin Yak from gascony in the Southwest
is made from wine distilled in Oak casks
and it's the oldest recorded Brandy in
France
cognacs also are wine Brandy named after
town in Portugal region in the west
where it must be made to be classified
as cognac
Calvados is an apple brandy made from
distilled cider and comes from Normandy
the French cooked with Brandy a lot and
tend to ignite or flombe it to bring
amazing depth of flavor to dishes like
the chicken fricassee I'm serving for
dinner
France has justifiably famous for his
cheeses and one of my favorites is Ghost
cheese
called Chev in French they produce
hundreds of types from the very mild and
creamy to the strong and pungent and
because it's so delicious the French
keep most of it for themselves and only
export a tiny amount luxurious soft
ghost cheese goes perfectly well with
sweet pears and earthy walnuts in the
open sandwich I'm making for lunch
when I was living in France I got to
know two very distinct traditions of
French food on the one hand there was
the delicious oat Cuisine I cooked all
day in the restaurant and on the other
hand there was the food you ate in
people's homes which is a lot simpler to
make but still absolutely delicious
My ultimate French inspired lunch it's
very light bright and really takes me
back to when I lived in Paris
it's my take on the salad misoise served
with a delicious goat cheese and pear
Tartine
think of the nisoise as an assembly job
of delicious ingredients brought
together with a fantastic dressing the
secret behind mine salad niswas is in
the dressing
spoon Dijon mustard into a pestle and
mortar some people top the salad with
Anchovies and capers but in mine they're
the base to the dressing we're going to
grind that to a paste
and then get the garlic in there season
well with black pepper
foreign
because of the anchovies add a couple
tablespoons of red wine vinegar olive
oil and lastly flat leaf parsley to give
the dressing freshness against those
deep flavors they say thick Rich
substantial dressing dressing done now
for the salad ball potatoes green beans
and eggs from a rolling ball seven and a
half to eight minutes it should keep
that nice yolky creamy texture in the
center once the eggs are ready put them
into cold water to stop them cooking and
this is a great trick to peel them
so much easier peeling eggs when you use
the water
but they've been cooling down in and the
water will seep underneath all the shell
and so the whole shell just gets peeled
off with one beautiful big layer
now beans
hmm
nice and crunchy season the beans and
potatoes whilst they're still warm so
they absorb more flavor a little drizzle
of olive oil salt pepper
and just let them sit there whilst the
potatoes and beans cool down I'm doing a
simple French Open sandwich which is
called a Tartine
it's delicious
first I'm toasting baguette on the
griddle
like the oil
a griddle pan get your bread
stick it on there
take a pair
it goes brilliantly well with goat's
cheese slice the pear into finger width
pieces
the color we're looking for that dark
crispy texture now for the goat's cheese
give it a season
doesn't need salt
because a little fresh ghost cheese is
already quite salty then a handful of
crumbled walnuts
they go under the grill whilst I put the
tuning these ones together
my secret to assembling a great nicoise
salad is the start in the middle of the
plate and add ingredients layer by layer
so there's one thing I'm always missing
the bottom of salads is dressing so I
like to put it on the plate first baby
gem lettuce is great because it's robust
and holds that heavy dressing then add
firm waxy salad potatoes and green beans
I like them to have a bit of a crunch
canned tuna can be fantastic I'm using a
good quality one in olive oil which has
been drained next baby plum tomatoes
which have a lovely intense sweet flavor
and then my eggs that nice dark Rich
yolk useful
yogurt's still creamy
inside
he's a little Olive nisoise this will
work just as well with other black
olives and then the dressing
drizzle that round gently beautiful
that is a nisswas in heaven now Tartine
wow just a smell
of those grilled walnuts
that is beautiful
a simple but very elegant
tuna nisswas
but delicious goat's cheese sandwich
[Music]
my vibrant and gutsy nisoise salad with
that incredible anchovy and Caper
dressing so with a pear and goat cheese
Tartine too good to let the French keep
it all to themselves
[Music]
coming up it's dinner time helping me
cook my ultimate French dinner is my
youngest daughter Tilly who's dressed
for the occasion I do not want to get
those little slippers caught on fire
what are their names Grandpa and Judith
I'm sharing The Wonder of cooking how
cool is that magical
Jack's gonna love this looks delish
[Music]
[Applause]
in general I think it's pretty fair to
say that whether they're rich or poor
the French are a nation of food
obsessives and one of the biggest
lessons I absorbed when I was over there
was the central importance of great
ingredients
I'm not the only one in my family who
loves French food
joining me in the kitchen today is my
youngest daughter Tilly who adores it
made with fantastic chicken cooked using
a classic but simple French technique
this is my ultimate home-cooked French
dinner first chop my chicken fricassee
do you mind helping daddy with the
chicken fricassee please
we're going to start off with Browning
oh
the chicken off nicely
pan on get that nice and hot what I want
you to do for me first is to season
a chicken with salt and pepper please
thank you so that's on one side then we
turn the chicken over
so we season it on the other side
salt good girl and pepper nice
now this is almost like a chicken stew
okay what's that there
[Music]
um time
good girl what's that one there
that's right Rosemary and because this
is quite a rustic French dish we don't
need to chop everything so you get the
garlic
and you just bash it like that now smell
that's right so that's nice and hot put
a tablespoon of olive oil in there a
couple of gloves
one two good kill
the chicken in
it and you lay away
you got that nice and brown getting good
at this you are
skin side down so we got the color on
the skin now I just want you to cut the
mushrooms in half the belly please okay
these are Chestnut mushrooms there are
lots of different types of mushrooms out
there there are lots and lots of
different types of mushrooms which one's
your favorite one of my favorites is the
Giro mushroom I like mushrooms that are
a bit bigger than this and
um some dinners with mum we cut out the
middle put pesto and cheese in it and
then we bake them oh so I want you to
sprinkle pancetta over the chicken
please
good girl
nice the machine did not yet because I'm
going to get some color on the chicken
first
okay
and as that pancetta
started to cook down it puts a really
nice flavor on the chicken yeah yeah so
we're sort of soaking everything okay
right garlic in please good girl just
throw them in
and I want you to sprinkle the mushrooms
on top of that good girl
and then there's a rosemary you can get
your fingers like that and you pull it
down you take it all off
hold it
put it down good girl so now you've got
the nice little Rosemary sprigs and we
do the same with the time now the thyme
flower is a little bit smaller what
different flavors do they give so the
thyme is a little bit sweeter okay and
the Rosemary a little bit more Savory
which ones you like I like them both
because they both give a nice smell
don't they so they Leaf in
I'd like you to put that Rosemary and
Thyme in there please
lovely sprinkle it over right I'd like
you to stand back now because we're
going to flambe this I do not want to
get those little slippers caught on fire
what are their names
and Judith Judith nice okay great ready
yeah him with a brandy
and then just tilt the pan gently
[Music]
all the cognac has been flambe so
there's no raw alcohol anywhere so we've
got a really nice deep rich flavor I'm
gonna add my chicken stock you know
Grandpa likes that not my slipper one
for room for the dog ah Rumple the dog
well he likes chicken stock yes when
he's a good boy he gets him he gets it
in his um with his biscuit it's gone and
like wow really quickly simmer and
reduce the stock for around 10 minutes
now we're going to keep the most amazing
potatoes
so do potatoes are really simple to make
and absolutely delicious start by
slicing the potatoes into finger whipped
pieces then parboil them for five to six
minutes when you cook something like
Rosemary or thyme or basil because it
slowly let off the flavor into the hot
oil very much so
in a hot pan add a tablespoon of goose
fat and saute the potatoes until they
turn golden
and add in shallots garlic Rosemary and
Thyme
that goes in
over top
and that goose fat now is starting to
fry the potatoes you just leave that sap
there
to complete my ultimate French dinner my
version of a classic a glorious lavender
creme caramel for dessert
the first job is the lavender's sugar
you can buy this ready-made or simply
add dried edible sprigs of lavender to
caster sugar and store you can also try
this trick with vanilla pods and
cinnamon to bring new subtle flavors to
sweets and bacon
[Music]
for the creme caramel melt plain caster
sugar until it turns dark golden
pour into ramekins sprinkle with
lavender flowers and cool
now to make a simple custard gently heat
whole milk in a pan until steaming
meanwhile whisk together egg vanilla
seeds and lavender sugar until golden
and fluffy then gradually pour the hot
milk into the mix whisking continuously
until the custard is smooth and creamy
set cook in a water bath or bammari a
good tip is to line a roasting tin with
a cloth to stop the ramekins jiggling
around pour your custard
then boiling water around the ramekins
until halfway up the sides then cook in
a preheated oven for around 30 minutes
until set
cool in the fridge then when you're
ready to serve dip the ramekins in hot
water to loosen the creme caramel
[Music]
caramel
foreign look at that chicken now
so I'm just gonna turn the gas right
down
and put the lid on
just like that but leave a little bit so
it can net out some stuff so I can let
out some steam that's right
now what I'd like to do is to chop Deli
some parsley crunch it up nicely tuck
your fingers in and take your time
[Music]
now my hands have got lots of different
names they've got all those wonderful
flavors you could almost be French
sprinkle that on there
good girl
nice
messy bookoo
no potatoes of chicken I can tell Jack's
gonna love this is he looks delish
doesn't it
before you took the lid off let's get on
my darling good job by the way thank you
I can't wait for the others to try it I
hope they love it this is my ultimate
French dinner chicken fricassee with
Sensational Herbie soda potatoes and
lavender creme caramel mag Jack mom and
Holly oh so nice doesn't it
no Daddy who's the one that burnt the
garlic
how could you dad
trust you to find that Jack potatoes I
thought you'd like these ones
oh no way
potatoes I love burnt garlic
Bon Appetit and look out for the burnt
garlic it was supposed to be crispy but
you've known the difference between
crispy and burnt
do you know what I think your daughter
might take after you
hi sous chef cheers
this is my home
this is my kitchen
this is my family Tilly
Jack
Holly
Megan
and of course my wife Tana
you may think you're the busiest person
in the world but over this series I'm
gonna prove it's still possible to cook
stunning food at home
[Music]
my rules are simple home cooking has to
be easy
it's gonna be fast it's got to be
delicious
so if you think you can't cook amazing
food at home think again
these are the only recipes you'll ever
need breakfast lunch and dinner
[Music]
today I'm taking my cue from Italy a
country that takes home cooking family
and fresh vibrant flavors extremely
seriously the Italians are brilliantly
using good food to bring people together
as well as being delicious today's
dishes are also really quick and easy to
make leaving you more time to sit down
and enjoy them with your friends and
family first up in my ultimate Italian
food a deliciously tasty breakfast of
fennel sausage frittata
it's light fluffy and it smells
incredible next a lunch to whisk your
way to Italy in the first portfolk
grilled sardines with gremolata and also
pasta salad fresh clean almost if we're
sat on him Alpha Coast
and as boys joined forces as Jack helps
me cook an incredible dinner with dishes
from the length and breadth of Italy
starter from the south quick fig Jam
crostini with creamy burrata
from the north a hearty slow-cooked beef
cheek Ragu with Papa Deli well when you
cook this for your girlfriend one day
just tell her where you got the recipe
for money promise promise
rounding off with a Tuscan inspired
dessert luxurious espresso panna cotta
with cinnamon hazelnut brittle Maggie
how is it Danny it's so tasty follow
these ultimate recipes and you too can
Embrace breakfast lunch and dinner the
passionate Italian way
starting with breakfast a fennel sausage
frittata
foreign thing about frittata is the fact
there's no set recipe because it's
basically eggs whatever else you have
left
for me the secret of a good frittata is
in the sausage nice hot pan onions in
getting this on the onions Heat
nice and high season
fennel seeds forgive the onions
a really nice flavor everyone's used to
cooking sausages whole
but it's a really nice way of using them
to take them out of their thin skin
what we're going to do is crumple all
that wonderful spicy fennel sausage into
the onions it's going to release all
that flavor a lot quicker
pretty important to keep that gas nice
and high and the longer you caramelize
the sausage the more flavor
you're gonna gain
six whole eggs give the eggs a really
good mix
flat leaf parsley a staple in Italian
cooking chop it
quite rough
some Parmesan
it gives a really nice seasoning fresh
pepper
a little touch of salt
and then get it in there
run your fork through it so when you
slice it no one's complaining they've
got less sausage
I'm gonna make it even more Italian by
topping it with some Buffalo mozzarella
dry it and then slice it nice and thinly
twist it
mozzarella in
and then finally finish it with our
panzan cheese get the top just as tasty
as it is the bottom
frittata needs three and a half to four
minutes under a red Hot Grill to achieve
the best results always ensure your oven
or grill are preheated to the perfect
temperature this is the thing I love
about Italian cooking it's about sharing
but always focusing on the ingredients
look at that
I mean it's incredible a little shake
the pan to make sure it comes out and
then spatula underneath and just leave
it
it's light
fluffy and it smells incredible and that
for me is a dream come true it's amazing
how far you can take six eggs and two
sausages
wow
spicy fennel sausage frittata My
ultimate Italian breakfast it's a
cracking start to the day
[Music]
Italian food puts a premium on fantastic
ingredients cooked simply
here's a bit of help on what to look for
when you're buying some of the key
ingredients for today's lunch and dinner
for dinner tonight I'll be cooking value
for money beef cheek
large meaty muscle can cost as little as
two pounds of Pop from your local
butcher but the rewards of cooking it
with a little love and Patience are
Bountiful
slash fried the meat from this
hard-working muscle is very tough but
slow braising will transform into four
Falls of melt in your mouth
deliciousness
I'll be using this cheeky cut for a
deliciously cheap Italian dinner that
will feed a whole family
[Music]
burrata one of Italy's most recent
cheesy exports was invented back in the
1920s from a need to make use of the
little scraps of mozzarella left in the
cheese making that
shreds are mixed with cream and encased
in a hand spun mozzarella pouch
this luxurious rich pugal and delicacy
is now becoming more popular in our
supermarkets
[Music]
if I had to choose one herb synonymous
with Italy this would be it basil the
perfect partner for tomato based dishes
or pounded with Parmesan and pine nuts
for a delicious pesto
Basil's soft silky aromatic leaves will
bring a taste of the Mediterranean to
any dish they touch and I'll be using it
in my ultimate Italian lunch
in much of Italy lunch is traditionally
seen as the most important meal of the
day and for a food assassination that's
really saying something whenever or
whatever Italians cook they always put a
premium on straightforward fresh food
prepared simply that's why Italian food
is so brilliant for the home cook for my
ultimate Italian lunch I'm cooking
scrutiny sardines topped with a fragrant
gremolata dressing but first a
deliciously fresh orzo pasta salad this
is one of the Hidden Delicacies of
Italian pasta also because 90 of the
time it's always hidden in a soup or
brothel minestrone and it looks like
large grains of rice but once they
absorb that water they double in size
It's a pasta that needs a lot of help
season it nicely pinch of salt and
splash of extra virgin olive oil fresh
bay leaf into the boiling water and that
bay leaf really helps to flavor the
pasta give you a little pan
turn left and right that stops any pasta
sticking to the bottom and the secret
behind cooking any pasta is having a
nice gentle rolling boil you just have
the gas up where the outside of the pan
is just rolling and all that also is
tumbling over each other gently boiling
past the rapidly tends to destroy the
outside texture it doesn't take the
marinade or the vinaigrette or the sauce
for the dressing parmesan Twist of fresh
pepper the zest of the lemon I'll
squeeze your lemon in there through your
fingers to catch all those seeds bring
that together with some extra virgin
olive oil
pine nuts taste delicious toasting them
just elevates them
after eight minutes my orzo is perfectly
al dente
train it a little bit of cold water
through it close the cooking process
down let's stop it from going mushy it's
the size of pumpkin seeds now a drizzle
of olive oil and into the vinaigrette
whilst it's still warm
just above room temperature because the
warmer the pasta the more it absorbs the
vinaigrette and now some texture rocket
not finely chopped
on the fresh basil as well
roll them up like a big fat cigar slice
in half
and then chop the basil
crunch just sprinkle the toasty pine
nuts
it looks like a plate of jewels glistens
they're delicious very fragrant also
pasta salad now for sardines incredibly
healthy and absolutely delicious grilled
never ever be intimidated on looking for
fresh fish it's about the condition of
the fish Bright Eyes fresh gills nice
bright red interior and the firmness of
the flesh almost you could stand the
fish up on his own it needs to be that
fresh the best way to get flavor into
sardine is to grill it light seasoning
olive oil
and just roll the seasoning around
get your Rosemary peel off a few of the
little shards at the end so it's a
little bit sharp push the Rosemary in
almost like a Threading makes them so
much more flavoursome
they'll be scared of those fine little
bones I remember growing up with
sardines tin sardines you didn't tongue
your nose up at the bone once The
Griddle pan starts to smoke lightly
drizzle and then sardines on
two and a half for three minutes each
side
now for the grandma Lata a pretty great
that sits beautifully well on the
sardines freshly parsley just run the
knife once nothing worse when you over
chop parsley and all that delicious
flavors left on the board the zest and
juice of an orange and a lemon
she'll turn them now
grandma that's about fragrance natural
flavors
brilliant for grilled Meats as well
little touch of salt
and pepper
and then olive oil just to bring it
together
the garlic I almost want to be like a
secret weapon in there
raise it
bring that together you've got a very
fresh clean gremolata almost if we're
sat on the Amalfi Coast
[Music]
off
then once the sardines are still nice
and warm and just thinly
coat gremolata
I'd like the passing the garlic to sit
on top and that's citrus from the lemon
and the orange to sort of dive
underneath
see why Italian cuisine rides on the
freshest and the simplest execution they
allow their ingredients to become the
hero
not the chef
also salad with stunning grilled
sardines
[Music]
wherever you eat this dish it will fill
your senses with the sun and the Sea of
the Mediterranean delicious
[Music]
[Applause]
one of the things I really admire about
the Italian approach to food is not just
how they cook but how they eat and enjoy
food too it's very very relaxed and it's
all about sharing great food with
friends and family our home life is
pretty hectic so when we're all at home
together we try and have a bit of
Italian Spirit at Meal Time
right my ultimate Italian dinner
[Music]
this is one of the kids favorites
and I've got Jack helping me in the
kitchen
wow
we're hoping to wow the family with an
amazing quick fig Jam crostini with
creamy burrata and the hearty Mane a big
cheat Ragu with Papa Deli beef cheeks
just think the size of your little
cheeks yeah imagine the size of a cow
with them and the cheek is right
underneath here yeah
um
I want you to give him a really nice
season with salt and pepper on there
please so beef cheeks very cheap my cut
that takes sort of a long time to cook
yeah but give it a bit of love let it
cook in the oven it comes out like a
dream a little touch
of oil in the pan what we want to do is
get them really nicely colored said into
the pan oh cool layaway
get what that is
um
[Music]
sitting at the dock of the
Beach
and then I want the onion chunky because
we're gonna cook it for like
three three and a half hours so you go
down
[Music]
and then again there and there so it
doesn't overcook
so a really good color on the cheeks
like that so how do you cook these at a
restaurant if they take so long they go
in the oven literally half past six
seven o'clock in the morning three and a
half four hours you ready for lunch and
the longer you leave them in their
juices yeah and the cooking liquor the
better King eyes closed the garlic good
onions in and garlic in please nice
where's your Bailey there it is yes
get those onions and that garlic really
nicely colored
put the cheeks back in place right red
wine in cool okay the red wine is going
to deglaze the pan so deglaze will
basically sort of rinse all that flavor
off the bottom of the pan yeah okay
because that's going to make the most
amazing sauce
now you could use tomato puree but
chopped canned tomatoes you'll make a
much better sauce I'm going to top that
with some stock so the secret of
braising is having little of the meat
exposed and 90 of it submerged see them
there yeah
they're like little crocodile heads
popping up out the water turn the gas
off and leave the lid just off at the
end there if we had to cover it
completely the steam hits the top yeah
the lid and all that water comes running
back solar still that's right in the
oven
140 150 for about three and a half to
four hours good job
Boom for pudding I'm making one of my
absolute favorite Italian desserts Banna
cotta with that quintessentially Italian
flavoring espresso
start by immersing two leaves of gelatin
in cold water and leave to soak
into a small saucepan add caster sugar
cream milk
sugar and a shot of good strong coffee
gently bring to a simmer and remove from
the hob
[Music]
wheeze out the soaked gelatin leaves and
stir into the hot cream until completely
dissolved
pour your cream mixture into a jug and
fill your molds just short of the rim
rinsing your molds in cold water before
filling will make it easier to get your
panna cotta out once it's set
[Music]
leaving the fridge for at least two to
three hours or overnight
foreign
[Music]
to make your cinnamon hazelnut brittle
pour caster sugar into a pan and cook
over medium Heat
until the sugar melts to a deep golden
brown
[Music]
scatter toasted hazelnuts into the
caramel
dust with ground cinnamon and leave to
set at room temperature
when your panna cotta is firm given each
mold a quick dip into boiling water
should ensure a perfect stress-free exit
onto the plate
foreign
[Music]
of crunchy hazelnut brittle nothing
could be so deliciously elegant
right Captain Jack quick run through
Panna cottas are nearly set beef cheeks
are nearly cooked we're gonna now do the
Fig and brighter crostini oh okay let's
take the figs we're gonna make a nice
slightly spicy fig Jam take off the tops
yep in half and each half into three
sugar a touch of salt in there okay
we're making a jam but we don't want a
bit too sweet and then these little
babies
what are they
ah What's a shape stars star underneath
taken from the fantasy plant yeah and
when you dry them like that so
intensifies the flavor really important
to count how many put in there okay yeah
so one two three four five so they're
just there from flavors and take them
out that's right secret here let's get
that camera going so when I hear a jam I
don't think of caramel no but this is a
very fast champ caramel's starting to
color
I want you very carefully to drop the
figs in there good
so the juice out of the figs
is starting to break down the camera
you know what that is I'll sweep it in I
love that on my challenge got that sort
of sweet and sour flavor leave that
cooking for three four minutes
now let's slice out chapata in Italian
crostini means little bits of toast but
it could be made out of leftover
baguette sourdough or any crusty open
textured bread we're staying
authentically Italian with ciabatta
season them and then drizzle a little
touch of olive oil on there both sides
really important because we're going to
grill the bread push it down
put some lovely very lovely take it off
with the chapata toasted we need to
carefully extract the star anise pods
from our piping hot fig Jam
my Jack we've got one little bugger to
five oh no
is it there yes it is right now we've
got the green light to crush
[Music]
skins disintegrated in that caramel that
looks so nice
oh Jack carefully spreads the crostini
with our hot fig Jam I can unveil the
last element to our starter the creamy
Italian specialty borata
and little money bags
delicious
this looks fun doesn't it
you need to season them lightly drizzle
over a little olive oil and dust them
with lemon zest imagine that sat there
and you tear some of that off and you
stick it on top of that and
back to the main course to match our
hearty beef cheeks I've chosen to use
papradelli rule number one when cooking
pasta
salt in first salt and first good olive
oil in
pasta in
twist it round so you don't break it no
bring that back on the ball that's going
to take back three or four minutes
flat leaf parsley scrunch it up for me
yep and chop him now wait to see these
beef cheeks beauties
look at them
they're very soft tiny I want you to
taste
um
it's so good
yeah you've just dribbled on your jumper
really
right drain the pasta
salt pepper
pasta little drizzle
of olive oil
I'm going to put your fresh parsnip
nicely chopped nicely chopped
in
this is the magic bit okay you take a
little Ladle of the juice
put that at the bottom
cook
the pasta
on top of that sauce
honestly oh my gosh your sisters are
going to love you even more now you know
what about when you cook this for your
girlfriend one day
uh just tell you where you got the
recipe from William promise promise I
don't want you stealing Daddy's Thunder
one
beautiful jaw on there two beautiful
Jaws on there
and then the third job and then you go
over with the sauce how cool is that
delicious you've got the orasa
and I've got the cheeks
let's go
[Music]
don't be cheeky get it
my ultimate Italian dinner
Frank Jam crostini with creamy borata a
main course of slow cooked beef cheek
Ragu with Papa Deli and for pudding
espresso panna cotta with cinnamon
hazelnut brittle
a stunning meal to bring the whole
family together in the best Italian
tradition
chili Meg we've got some cheeks for you
[Music]
money bag thank you
how creamy is that a touch more cheek
check please oh yes please of course you
can
Maggie how is it darling it's so tasty
silly what's your favorite part I really
like the the cheese
thank you
it's not funny is when somebody grabs
the other cheek start worrying well the
right one